TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
To improve security,
insecure TLS version fallback
has been removed from
HttpsURLConnection
in Android O. While
most apps will not
be affected by this change,
the easiest way to be sure
is to build and test your app
with the Android O Developer
Preview.
Details and links are on the
post linked in the description
below.
TensorFlow Sequence-to-Sequence
is now available.
It's an open source
sequence-to-sequence framework
in TensorFlow that makes
it easy to experiment
with sequence-to-sequence
models and achieve
state of the art results.
Links to the papers and the
GitHub are on the posts.
We've partnered with
Udacity to offer
a free two-day
interactive course that
will help you learn how to use
Firebased Analytics to grow
your user base on
iOS and Android.
You'll see how to
set goals, how to log
users' interactions
with an app, and even
analyze real data from an app
that's live in the Google Play
Store and in the App Store.
If you'd like a way to automate
creating Google Cloud Platform
projects, either because
you have a lot of them,
or maybe you want to
standardize project
creation for your company,
well, you're in luck.
Google Cloud Deployment
Manager is the native GCP tool
that you can use to create
and manage GCP resources,
including Compute Engine,
Container Engine, Cloud SQL,
BigQuery, Cloud Storage, and now
to create and manage projects
as well.
Get started with a post linked
in the description below.
We subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode of the Dev Show.
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over
here, on your right--
my left, your right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]